bonjour bienvenue sur les côtés avec
l'en baptiste moreau stephen alors
aujourd'hui jean mathis on va voir la
variante française alors variante austin
voilà on va dit tennis ou armes
classiques
donc on a deux possibilités sur le coup
calice et trois dans la française soit
on joue la wind power soit on joue la
baroque classique
donc on va t'aider noir qui choisissent
en fait c'est une mort qui choisissent
alors c'est notre force timmy sans
rappeler qui s'est quand même c'était le
premier champion du monde ça date un
autrichien 1886 enfin si je ne sais pas
aussi par la danse c'est aulas c'est
voilà donc
qui qui donc a fait beaucoup pour la tv
d ouverture d'ailleurs je crois même
d'ailleurs c'était un modèle pour fisher
un fischer repris des idées steinitz
parce que sentant pas tout à fait son
temps mais quand même bien une 80 ans
j'ai raisonné après donc c'est quand
même un très très grand joueur parce que
les bases positionnelle d ouverture de
ce timing c'était quand même très saine
très saine voilà donc en avance a donc
une possibilité pour les noirs de varier
sur défense française on va voir après e
4 e 6 des quatre des cinq cavaliers c3
voilà donc on maintient à la tension est
là
donc au lieu du couffo becali
caractérise la variante we know where
donc ici je couds lecavalier 3 ca
s'élève en dinars web et là on joue la
vente steinitz qui est le coup cavaliers
psy soit là cavalier f6 donc qui pose la
question au plus quatre autres sans pour
autant proposer un échange tu es fou de
15 mois comme la vente une horreur
alors il ya quand même un gros
inconvénient par rapport à la wind power
c'est que bien sûr la réponse qui est
identique finalement c'est le coût 1,5
le coin c'est bien là le cavalier est
obligé de reboucher mais l'avantagé
c'est qu'on ne s'est pas affaiblie en
donnant la perte de fou en tout cas on
ne s'arrête pas à le faire et on a quand
même réussi à forcer les blancs à
déterminer la structure de pions au
centre les cantons renseigné sur la
place des pions au centre pour toute la
partie parce que l'on sait qu'ils
ouvrent pas à moins d'être échangé bien
sûr eh bien on sait comment les attaquer
et on sait comment placer nos pièces et
notre lancée d'une information qui est
très important dans toutes les
ouvertures
il est très important d'avoir la
certitude de la place des pions comme
français ouvrent être nos ouvrages est
passé de pièces fait donc la qualif 17
le coup un coup classique dans la
française un soin sont en a pas on n'a
pas trente six cases un cahier 8 ça
serait un peu
on peu bizarre un peu bizarre alors là
on va voir deux possibilités notamment
le coup
alors le coût principal cf4 on peut
peut-être que la montre est tout
simplement là c'est le coup qui défend
tranquillement tout simplement qui
renforce la défense aucune scène et qui
va permettre ajouté relief trois
tranquillement voilà en fait la
formation qu'ont donné les blancs aux
noirs c'est à dire les pions vous
attendez 4,5
l'information n'est pas visible que pour
les noirs les blancs aussi savent que
l'option sont là et qu'ils vont se faire
attaquer ici donc la réaction classique
des noirs c'est toujours la pousser ses
voilà donc avant le coup au f91
on sait déjà que les noirs dont
jouissent ses cinq as maintenant on a
deux possibilités soit on est d'accord
pour échanger notre plan des 4 contre le
pion saissac ce qui n'est pas
inintéressant puisque ça nous offre une
caisse des quatre intéressante
soit on a déjà prévu de protéger le pion
des quatre avec notre pion aux quelqu'un
d'autre cas au lycée 3 est mal placée
c'est la raison pour laquelle on joue
cavalier ce2 alors l'autre possibilité
sur ses possibilités c'est le cas à
l'essai vient de soi cavalier seul en
tête voir cette deuxième piscine aurait
d'abord voici un coût qui me plaît qui
me plaît bien je trouve que c'est un
coût qui est récente positionne helmand
alors c'est un jeu c'est un joli coup
parce que comment on joue cavalier mais
les noirs déjà aussi l'allier mais en
fait en bloc le fou mais c'est une
position fermée et on va jouer c'est de
ses 300 sans casser notre violence dont
en gardant notre belle une belle très
belle comme la ligne depuis on entre
dans notre fief ans qui est bloqué
provisoirement et bien et effectivement
on n'est pas prêt avec les blancs à une
ouverture du jeu rapide mais c'est
justement l'idée sur ces cinq ans vous
et ses trois enfants gardent le sens de
fermer dont la cdc un coût qu'il est
très cohérent avec l'esprit de la
position qu un joli coup en fait qu'un
jeu du groupe c1 on rejoue la pièce bon
alors je précise que c'était joué par
les plus grands joueurs mais on ne s'est
pas un coût marginal
bien sûr c'est un coût important le c5
logique pour les noir sans ce coup là
l'activité des blancs et droit va être
géré ou l'aube selon lui manqueront
continuer le développement et tout temps
en incorporant le plan c 5 dans notre
attaque c'est le vrai un nouveau central
de la défense française un jeu très peu
de français ce jour j'ai passé sinon on
se fait on se fait tout simplement
étouffé alors c2 c3 logique là on voit
bien que c'est on a une belle une très
belle structure de pions diriger et puis
si on voit bien vers les lois et donc
avec une potentialité date à calais le
rang alors que les noirs eux leur jeu
ici on voit avec leurs chaînes de pions
ça c'est comme ça qu'on détermine aussi
par où exactement
on a beaucoup d'ouvertures en sont
plutôt l danois là on sait où on va
réaliser les percées de pions les
perceptions c'est pour ouvrir des
colonnes donc effectivement des les
noirs ont déjà trouvé lors de ces cinq
donc c'est effectivement alors ce sera
la colonne c et puis les blancs eux ils
ont une perception dans la case f5 voilà
f4 f5 est un pion blanc qui peut aller
très vite cette case là parfois aidé de
g4 aussi souvent aussi il faut alors
qu'avaient laissé six pour les noirs
donc logique
on renforce aussi ici la pression sur
des cas de même si des cats pour
l'instant est bien protégé avec ses
trois as les cavaliers ou deux oui mais
ça peut aller vite au fond de soi f 4 4
l'idée c'est de consolider vraiment
notre notre centre de pions là on voit
que la formation des pions blancs est
très impressionnante
oui parce qu'on veut pouvoir aussi
éventuellement prendre système qui peut
être un jour peut-être est en gardant le
contrôle de 5 voilà en tout cas un beau
tacle de pleureuses que 5 soit soit
dépendant de la seule défense du club
des quatre
et puis on veut aussi développer notre
cavalier g1 sur la case f3 et pourquoi
se passer du plan f on va voir ce à
dessein un point noir ça c'est un coup
logique à bien comprendre si c'est une
idée très importante de cette position
avec les noirs six mois ne joue pas ça
ils vont être complètement ficelé il
faut que les noirs continuent leurs
attaques sur l'ale dame en s'aidant du
pion b5 alors leur profil que le fouet
enfants et bien et est enfermé
mais pour pouvoir taper sur loix la
permission donc on se permet de jouer b5
pour jouer rapidement ensuite de coupe
des 4 et oui parce qu'on veut saper
toute la chaîne de pions ici et ouvrir
les lignes du côté dames
alors pourquoi faire jouer les pièces
donc ça explique le coup suivant des
blancs dont tout est logique à 3 oui
voilà donc là on voit que la paix la
chaîne youtube en anjou à fond sur les
15 mois ce qui enterre momentanément un
peu saoul sud ailleurs un fossé voilà
mais quand le pion au f4 à bouger relève
5 le phocéen va retrouver leur chemin un
peu d'air de l'avion assurait alors la
6e' après le coût à 3 les blancs tout
grosse menace grosse menace
positionnelle bien sûr ils veulent jouer
b4 ils veulent jouer b4 ici pour
enfermer décider de qui on sait 5 soit
poussé ces quatre ce qui clôt le débat
halal dames c'est le terme ils veulent
clore les débats allaient elles dames et
apprendre des mains libres sur le droit
soit prendre avec et après pions en c3
les noirs les blancs un super remplaçant
c5
voilà pour un cavalier donc ce serait un
désastre
donc il faut que les noirs réagi à
l'arrivée agissent ils peuvent par
exemple prendre des quatre qui on prend
des quatre cavaliers prend des quatre
salles et prend 10 4 alors la bonne idée
quand même c'est de prendre des claques
sinon si on maintient les choses en
l'état ça veut dire que les noirs ne
peuvent plus jouer mais j'ai quatre les
blancs vont jouer cavalier 3 et vous
pouvez remplacer le camélidé quatre
parrains parle aux cavaliers si on fait
comme suit 1 alors qu'en faisant là tout
de suite camille camp des cats ont force
quasiment puis on prend des quatre
puisque sur dame prend les noirs
gagnerez du temps en se développant des
crous et sobre gagnerait du temps tout
simplement avec le couscous et 5 ce qui
est pas forcément l'objectif même si
c'est une position ferme et c'est pas
très grave mais c'est quand même
embêtant ce robuste heureux donc
l'idée pour les blancs ici c'est bien de
prendre des quatre avec le pion voilà
une structure qui est figé du côté les
noirs vers la colonne s'est aussi
peuvent la prendre éventuellement le
problème pour les sens tout de suite
c'est le pion v5 évidemment qui est
attaqué voilà et de toute façon la
menace des blancs c'est aussi bekkat
ainsi non seulement faut crever 5 à la
danse d'ailleurs c'est pas forcément
faux pro b 5e surtout prend bessin qui
aurait damas 5 et chaque nomination à la
chaîne mais l'idée encore une fois c'est
plutôt de b4 italia au qatar avec
consolidation la casse et 5 très belle
avant de postes pour pour un cavalier
ce serait très près donc les clés noires
sur le besoin de jouer les quatre mêmes
donc les noirs jouent eux la b4 en fait
ils veulent liquider toutes les dames
pas forcément d'ailleurs prendre un
avantage sur l'album et liquides ll
dames et on va se rendre compte qu'en
toutes les dames sera liquidée bien il
restera une structure avec cinq plans du
même côté et le pro des quatre qui est
un peu plus faible que les autres
grandes nations se tourner quatre est à
la base de la chaîne de pioche 45 ici il
peut être faible alors que ici il faut
aller attaquer points 7 qui est pas
vraiment une faiblesse puisqu'il est
40-13 enfoncé d'encre noire à 0 qui sera
est revenu sur un poste très reculées
donc c'est pas facile de l'attaqué donc
là les blancs empêche la liquidation et
jouent à 4 c'est un très joli coup à 4
passes trop se montrer que le fouet
fuites montrent là peu d'avenir et
maintenant il est bloqué par son pion à
ses 5 il est bloqué par le pion ici en
d6 il est bloqué alors est ce plus que
la case de 7 ce pauvre fou effectivement
très joli coup à 4 qui bloque nous le
ferons en fuite et qui empêche la
liquidation les dames tombent à la dame
à 5 $ et le tabassage fou des deux
recettes on développe les pièces
cavaliers f3 petit rock bon ça ce câble
et f3 on accélère un petit peu pour
montre le développement et la fougue et
ça c'est intéressant foulée 5
pourquoi c'est intéressant parce que les
noirs avaient dans l'idée de ce et
d'échanger leurs mauvais fou parfois 6 /
échanger ce fou contre le fouet f10 pu
faire le point avant peut-être aussi
nîmes voilà mais en tout cas sur e bay 5
populaire au bessat qui peuvent plus le
faire tout de suite les jeunes de
trouver une solution pour le cavalier et
de lemaître peut-être sur une case
maladroite et on le voit après le coup
suivant des blancs cb trois titres
puisque ce cavalier b6 finalement ne
fait plus rien
né voilà par le cube et rend leur cents
certes les noirs vont échanger leurs
trous voici semaine 6 devient à son tour
une mauvaise pièce faut prendre un civil
dames 3 600 prend 1,6 à cinq reculs
assez enclin en gagne de l'espace alors
ça ça évite aussi que les noirs eux
mêmes jouent à cinq plus tard aussi
oui et ça pose la question cavaliers oui
et puis l upload beckett qui commence à
être isolé des troupes
pas de morale c'est tombé 4 maintenant
convaincus que le fou en d2 peut faire
une action enfin elle coûtera 4 et lyon
a7 peut plus venir à sa rescousse il est
c'est une cible
voilà les contrées encore qui a été
scellé tôt demi coup suivant dame de tyn
de bien jouer
voilà on change de dames avec un petit
avantage positionnelle puisque le roi va
venir en d3 où il sera tranquille voilà
et on va s'en prendre ma tension option
b 4 par l'intermédiaire de cavaliers -
cavaliers detroit
car il ya un karim entre le parcours
présidentiel au caire bien sûr on peut
imaginer que le mot région d'abord
comprendre alors devoir vous rendrez la
colonne miku logique pour ces huit
peut-être tour au tour 6 1 quand même tu
sais bien voilà et le plan pour les
blancs alors là c'est laval liévin et
cavaliers des trop avec attac douala iv
et éventuellement un échange 8e tour à
cadres et éventuellement torah kawala
ayant suivi les choses reprend si vite
avec des problèmes pour les noirs qui se
retrouve à la défense de l'ordre de
leurs pions isolé et possibilité pour
les blancs de jouer sur cette menace
aussi pourquoi pas pour prendre la
colonne c'est tout simplement la fille
donc là on a compris pourquoi les blancs
tenait absolument à tenir le centre mais
parce que les pièces noires ont du mal à
trouver des cases intéressante voit la
main suivante l'idée cavaliers ce2
tunisie tout à fait respectable et donc
on peut vous l'a conseillé actuellement
contre cette ouverture même totalement
donc on revient sur la position de
départ alors autre possibilité les fds l
on accepte que la puissance et 5
violents des cats pour inviter notre
tueur à sortir du centre et on joue f4
on jouait en prenant les devants voilà
d'accord ça c'est l'autre option donc
c'est ça ok on en avait parlé alors ses
seins toujours pour les noirs donc
l'idée générale donc aller vite on n'a
plus besoin de la commenter celle ci
c'est du classique c'est vraiment le
coup qu'il faut jouer toujours cette
idée du pion c'est qui
du côté blanc du côté du noir souvent
doit pouvoir participer à l'attaqué
qu'on évite de bloquer autant que faire
se peut donc cavalière 3 le coup logique
se défend évidemment cavaliers ses fils
attend kbc signer deux mois se dirige
dans la contre attaque aussi gros et la
fois trois voies la bombe tranquille on
tient bien le tenir la caisse des cas
très important alors oui peut-être il ya
un tout petit souci c'est que ça a fait
une irruption de b2 donc on peut se
demander votre seulement évidemment ils
se postent avait six dames b6 da messina
oui bien sûr donc un coup classique sont
indécises alors qu'est ce qu'on fait sur
la baie trinité alors je crois qu'on est
inouï vous simple tout simplement car il
ya ka voilà on joue cavalier à 4 voilà
donc où il ya 4 qui a l'air pas bon
parce qu'on se dit mme attention il ya
un échec ici de la dame avec le cavalier
qui emprise mais classiquement en fait
non c'est c'est comme ça qu'il faut le
boire et se carrière non seulement ils
attaquent évidemment la dame v6 mais en
plus il attaque aussi pioncer 506
important voilà donc dames 5 c'est quand
même pas 5 et le coup quand même et là
en fait on peut protéger le cavaliere
directement parce qu'on joue c3 qui à la
fois empêche les chèques évidemment mais
en plus libère l'action de la dame des
hommes donc qui protège kayak aof
on a les bras en prise classique le
cavalier à quatre c'est vraiment la
bonne case mais il a toujours ce plan
c'est 5 à aller prendre si vraiment il
était en grand danger parlera pas le
coup bessin exactement ainsi b5
effectivement la part des noirs dans ce
cas là il ya pas de problème pour les
plantes puissent comprendre et en c5
sans soucis et non seulement sans souci
mais comment font les noirs parce que
s'ils reprennent
on devrait poindre une première fois
regagné et on pourra jouer des quatre
attaques les pros dribble se sentent
voilà donc chaud donc c'est ça serait
chaud donc apprécier 3 on peut dire que
les blancs
les blancs sont bien quoi il n'y a pas
de problème particulier là parce que la
menace des blancs c'est quand même de
provence est repassé sous les 4 voilà
tout à fait avec une expansion à la dame
finalement c'est lui qui prend ici
attire les dames donc comme ils sont
mieux les droits et prend l'initiative
les dames c'est les noirs sont ils tous
fait un des deux côtés donc
alors on en était à fouet 3 alors voilà
donc ici on vient nous dire qu'on a dit
que le couple d'un v6 n'était pas
forcément une très grande menace à une
vraie menace
on a vu l'astuce qui permet de condamner
l'attitude très important de redire à 4
à bien connaître à 6
voilà à fils donc là à 6 pour les noix
donc là l'idée c'est une idée classique
pour les noirs c'est de jouer b5 b4
voile allemand et de deux parce que là
l'idée nord c'est clairement d'attaqués
à la fois au centre irène dames et aux
blancs de tenir le centre fermement et
d'attac aller loin il va sacrer le roi
et même peut-être faire rock avec dame
d2 et gros rock
c'est la raison pour laquelle les noirs
préparent leur exposition sur le thème
pour les dix souhaitent des blessures
rock bien sûr voilà donc on regarde
cette suite entame de 2e année de bep 5
on a maintenant c'est clair après bessin
que les blancs font pas s'aventurer à
foix grand roque puisqu'après après b4
ces quatre jours là ça commence à faire
beaucoup et ça fera beaucoup de pion à
l'arrêt noir sur le sur le gros rock
donc c'est pas s'épanouir choix c'est
pas clair
là il ya plusieurs courts plus de
possibilités ici il ya eu un choix qui
est intéressant c'est de prendre ces 5
voilà que l'on avait toujours se poser
cette question en livrant fait danser
m'oriente oui pourquoi parce que c'est
un libé à la casse des cadres voilà pour
la liberté de gaz qui peut être une
belle avance en imaginant le cas ici
trois ans on peut très bien se retrouver
en de clients des 4 avec une finale
c'est un grand classique des procès cinq
français sont donc france et 5 l'on peut
échanger en c5 foot français c'est en ce
sens que moi là très bien voilà et la
dame f2 est intéressant de poser la
question aux cavaliers quand quelqu'un
sa série en contrôlent toujours la tête
et quatre reprises sa dalle sur la
colonne est fiable
c'est un coup politique ou
multifonctions la dame f2 2006 par
exemple foot est roi
alors faut savoir qu'on n'a pas peur de
donner son fou contre le cavalier c5
parce que à chaque fois qu'on veut juger
un échange de pièces n'oubliez pas qu'il
faut pas regarder ce qui parfois grèce
qui reste donc ce qui reste pour les
noirs c'est un cavalier est un fou s'est
vite très mauvais et pour les blancs ces
deux cavaliers ça veut dire notamment
que les blancs ne rompt pas de
difficulté à échanger un cavalier il
restera plus qu'à cavaliers contre le
mauvais goût c'est 8
bien sûr donc et noir n'ont pas intérêt
à faire des échanges trop trop rapide
donc le plan on l'a dit ici c'est petit
rock maintenant pour les blancs petit
rock pour préparer donc la poussée du
pion f éventuellement comme tu l'a
proposé stéphane cavaliers deux
cavaliers deux des quatre cargos
intéressant si un jour toujours à jouer
ce genre de plan ici voilà donc là on
arrête avant postes pour le cavalier qui
est très intéressant tout à fait tout à
fait donc alors sur ps1 qu'on a à trois
alors et l'autre possibilité
le tout se tient sur deux jours lequoy 3
donc pourra pour freiner cette expansion
des quatre qui pourraient se syndiquent
était la menace un des noirs on avait
besoin de jouer b4 et après ils ont
chois c4 par exemple ou b3 des choses
comme ça exact donc à 3 alors dame b 6
là on va suivre une partie du jeune
joueur d'azerbaïdjan radjabov wii party
qui était qui avait défrayé la chronique
à l'époque puisque c'était contre le
grand kasparov au tournoi de retour de
minarets ce wake island 3 qui demande
que la langue française et pas d'ennemi
devenait puisque même kasparov a perdu
pied
effectivement
une partie effectivement très historique
on peut dire qu'ils avaient énerver
passablement kasparov oui pourquoi parce
qu'elle avait obtenu le prix de beauté
du jury du grand tournoi de linares
selon kasparov c'est une partie qui ne
justifiait pas un prix de beauté mais là
c'est plutôt légaux qui veut parler il
avait même fait un scandale pendant la
wii
aujourd'hui les prix on est à fait tout
à provenant d'autres variantes d'un v6
cavalier e 2 donc le coût normal aussi
parce qu'on veut comme dans beaucoup de
variantes jeu quiz ces trois courses
assez classique aussi et puis on veut
aussi que d'autres cavaliers ses trois
soeurs un peu plus ce qu'ils valent et
se replace éventuellement sur les droits
sur la case d3 pourrait paraître coeff
c'est un peu aussi
voilà donc cesser nos possibilités et
puis toujours un oeil sur la caisse des
4 je crois que l'idée aussi principal du
fou cavaliers au dos on a compris ça te
prendre ces cinq provinces et ensuite de
ce cahier de l'avenir en décor bien sûr
donc sa sas justifier le coup suivant
des noirs voilà quelques ou c4 de rajab
alors c'est toujours un coup un petit
peu
on va dire responsable c'est ce qu'on
entend souvent quand on voit un coup
anti positionnelle comme ça mais c'est
vrai que en fait il veut pas que les cvo
blanc n'a qu'à deux des quatre il veut
continuer son expansion sur le dindon
qui jouissent ces quatre elle même si sa
ferme un peu la position
eh bien il va quand même pouvoir prendre
de l'espace sur les droits on va voir
qu'il a une idée précise
le problème de ce coup là c'est que les
blancs vont pouvoir en ont les mains
libres maintenant pour attaquer sur
l'ale rock et classique
le centre des firmes et maintenant donc
on y va g4 avec j 4 voilà un coup très
intéressant prépare f5
donc on l'idée c'est toujours pareil ces
deux cantons sont g4 évident c'est pour
jouer le coup et 5 pers et en os 6
affaiblir le pion aussi s'ouvrir aussi
la colonne f pour les tours et souvent
mais souvent ça passe il ya des attaques
qui absolument pers
donc la réponse mans avec classique
aussi classique puisque en fait les
blancs qu'on a pris la précaution de
journée coûte tour j'ai un corps et une
étroite aux cimes aussi exact exactement
en fait j'ai l'impression qu'ils se
fichent un peu de la réponse des noirs
qui pourtant est classique c'est à
chaque âge simple pourquoi parce que sur
h3 et bien la tour has en défense donc
pas jouer h3 évidemment puisque après h
projet 4 voilà dans l'idéal il faudrait
un village 3 pour garder lui la
structure de leur propre acte mais le
problème c'est que la tour achats et en
l'air mais il a une idée quelques
paroles fuji pro à 5,75 pour prend 1,5 à
taux plein et la cavalerie gilles 3com
l'elysée pour préparer la piste et f5
tout à fait tour à schwyz et à la f5
voilà mes donc l'idée de radjabov dans
cette variante très tendue de la
française est bien c'est de faire pions
prend f5 et ce cavalier prend f5 et bien
il ya une solution pour faire jouer une
pièce clé traditionnellement assez
faible dans cette ouverture pour les
noirs ceccarelli 17 et le zoom f6 voilà
une petite pointe tactique qui libère
l'action du fossé 8 sur le cavalier f5
et lecavalier avait six qui va pouvoir
retrouver sa place éventuellement en eux
quatre signes d'autres font pas
attention
il aurait même pu envisager pourquoi pas
de le prendre en russie qu'est ce qui se
passe il le prend alors si je prends
aussi le prend 5 le problème c'est que
le fou se libère voilà ça comprend ici
est en fait malheureusement il ya une
contre attaque sur la dame donc ça va je
pars dans leur sport il faut donc jouer
une découverte
peut-être pas lucratif entre guillemets
mais en tout cas professionnellement
intéressante pour remplacer des pièces
mais on voit très bien que ce qui
revient à une superbe clave place
évidemment en 4 bien manger 4 il peut
être intéressant
on va le voir d'ailleurs tout matin
après calais j'étais je crois donc
contrôler la catastrophe écologique est
donc là attaque le fou voilà donc c'est
là qu'on voit tout les toute la finesse
de la conception de radjabov donc c'est
une partie à méditer ça va si on joue
cette variante là évidemment qu'ils à
fait importante et sur fond f4 il a joué
vous aussi si on n'est peut-être pas
obligé d'aller jusqu'au bout de cette
nature de cette position de cette partie
ma foi fort intéressant vous pouvez
suivre on peut dire cette partie vous la
retrouver sur internet si vous tapez
dans ton co2 de 4 da rocha radjabov sur
la google vous allez trouver la
partition beaucoup de sources
différentes vous pourrez trouver la
partie et sur fotsis et bien on voit que
les bleu noir enfin grand roque et puis
bien ma foi les noirs otage de pièces
assez actif les blancs aussi voilà mais
c'est en tout cas une idée très
intéressante pour pour avoir une partie
way est libre et dynamique et même
kasparov a perdu cette partie dont il
voyait dans cette partie ça prouve que
le sait jouer les ressources noirs sont
quand même assez intéressants sont assez
intéressantes non voilà pour cette vente
steinitz
donc on a quand même on a vu les grandes
variantes rappelé les grandes lignes
voilà donc on vous laisse en chemin pour
les blancs cavaliers ce2a je crois que
vous êtes on n'a pas vu c'est le temps
rien autour des tracés d'adn les cartes
si si on aime la vie au grand dam yeux
on a tous vu très belle est vraiment
très vieille ce qui veut dire que
parfois même dans les vieilles marion on
va trouver des choses près la veille
tout à fait tout ce qu'on va conseiller
aussi bon on le répétera on le répète
dans d'autres le sont si vous en suivez
vous conseille évidemment regardé
plusieurs mais c'est c'est évidemment
tant que vous êtes amateurs
vous spécialiser sur quelques ouvertures
bien précise donc si vous voulez
française choisissez une variante que
vous allez bien connaître et
et ne changeait aux fourneaux ouvrez
votre répertoire une fois que vous
maîtrisiez déjà bien une variante quoi
faut éviter de se disperser
je suis tout à fait d'accord et c'est
vrai qu'il faut se spécialiser sur pied
une variante ennemis disons en tout cas
ne pas avoir un arbre de variantes trop
large et trop grands cela dit bien
connaître les ouvertures en général oui
c'est bien ça permet de bien jouer ses
propres ouverture c'est clair parce
qu'on voit quand même que dans toutes
ses dents toutes les leçons que l'on
vous propose les thèmes les principes
sont récurrents est ce qu'on peut
trouver même dans un grand bidane on
peut trouver la même idée dans une
française ce sont des principes qu'il
faut connaître et des réactions typiques
voilà tout à fait merci jean baptiste
pourquoi c'est superbe steinitz merci
bien thomas bientôt sur une autre leçon